ja liebe freunde ein klares plädoyer
grundsätzlich für die einer spitze
das möchte ich vorab betonen ja
thüringen funktioniert anders da haben
wir zwar spitze seit acht jahren und
führung funktioniert wie ihr alle wisst
sehr sehr gut das sind seltene glücks
konstellationen dies manchmal auch in
der partei gibt aber grundsätzlich sind
zweier spitzen konfliktträchtige aber
auch das ist die geschichte unserer
partei
wir haben immer wieder bundessprecher
gehabt mit denen der nazis durchgegangen
ist die irgendwann auf eine egoistische
linie über geschwenkt und umgeschwenkt
sind und da war es gut dass wir einen
zweiten bundessprecher hatten der
korrigierend eingreifen konnte also im
sinne der machtarithmetik im sinne des
ausgleichs der macht kann es auch
durchaus sinnvoll seine zweier spitze zu
haben aber ich denke wir kommen jetzt
langsam in eine phase der konsolidierung
wir sind dazu eine bürgerlich
konservative partei und ich bekenne mich
zur einzel spitze das bedeutet führung
in freiheit und verantwortung auf zeit
1 möchte ich jedoch betonen die antrag
der heute vorsieht ein generalsekretär
auch schon in die satzung zu
implementieren wäre meiner nach meiner
meinung nach verfrüht gestellt wir haben
in bremen 2015 die diskussion um den
generalsekretär abgebrochen wir müssen
uns erst mal klar machen was ist dieser
generalsekretär welche
kompetenzbereiche hdmi ist er eingefügt
in die vorstandsstruktur da müssen wir
noch darüber diskutieren bevor wir das
in die satzung implementieren soll also
mein petitum zum schluss mein credo zum
schluss wir beschließen heute das
umstellen unserer satzung wir streichen
die dreierspitze die glaube ich wirklich
nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist und wir setzen
da für die wahl zwischen einer und
zweier spitze wir machen das jetzt fix
für die satzung wir machen in diesen
durchlauf noch einmal eine zweier spitze
weil wir eben noch nicht die erfahrung
gemacht haben dass der buddhismus
auskommen ich komme zum schluss sehr
geehrter versammlungsleiter weil wir
leider als partei bisher noch nicht in
die erfahrung machen konnten dass der
bundesvorstand als neutrale instanz
geführt wurden in dieser bundesvorstand
ist immer wieder macht politisch
missbraucht worden deswegen hätte ich
gerne erstmal das erlebnis dass eine
instanz nur tragegefühl letzte
bundesvorstand neutral geführt wird und
deswegen bitte einer oder zweier spitze
in die satzung einfügen und dann wählen
wir dieses mal noch eine zwei spitzen
beim nächsten mal eine einer spitze
sowie in vielen dank